Good morning, John.
We are really, really lucky.
Here’s a thing that’s kind of hard for
me to think about: Over the last ten years,
we have had 1400 chances to try something
new, and in one way or another, sometimes
big sometimes super super tiny, we have tried
something new every single video.
Sometimes I humped things, sometimes you ate
toilet paper, sometimes I sang songs, sometimes
we went to the developing world.
We’ve done this publicly, with an audience
of varying sizes, and the success of those
attempts has been judged.
Judged by the number of views those things
got, what kind of audiences they attracted,
whether we liked doing them, how our friends
and families felt, whether we thought those
videos were interesting and good, and also
by people telling us what they thought in the comments.
In those 1400 chances, a lot of those ideas
were duds, but some of them were amazing.
I made a video with a person I met at a weird,
tiny research museum in Missoula, which led
to The Brain Scoop becoming a thing.
And you and I made videos on the French Revolution
and on the circulatory system that led to Crash Course.
It’s impossible to underestimate the effect
that this has had, not just on the kind of
stuff I make, but who I have become as a person.
If you count SciShow and Crash Course, I’ve
had thousands of chances to try and figure
out who I am in front of good people who I
respect.
And the kindness of their judgement, their
empathy and compassion and their wit and silliness,
and of course my own affinity for those things,
has made me a kinder, more enthusiastic, more
compassionate person.
We’ve had thousands of chances to evolve
our content, and thousands of chances to evolve
ourselves, and this has helped me clear up
the murky waters of what it is that I really care about.
It’s helped me find me.
And a lot of themes have emerged over the
years of us doing this, like areas of fertile
soil where I found stuff that I like making,
that I’m good at making, and that I feel
like is good for the world, and that people
like watching.
Sometimes those are formats, like kinds of
videos we can make.
Sometimes they’re just ideas.
Ways to consider the world.
For me, the most important time that happened
was when you distilled so much of what the
world needs right now into three words when
you said “imagine others complexly.”
Because it’s really hard, but whenever I
do it, I feel better, and I am better.
A lot of the projects that we have created
have Wikipedia pages, but this idea has a Wikipedia page.
It’s part of Wikipedia’s essays on civility.
That is unusual, and it’s amazing.
But of course, it isn’t just other people,
it’s the whole world.
We have to imagine the world in its complexity
as well, and not see that as a burden,
but as an opportunity.
Like, a wonderful wonderful thing that we
get to spend our whole lives doing.
And when I look back at the kind of content
that we make and that we've helped other people make,
that thing is always there in all of
it.
And when I think about what I want to make
in the future, if that isn’t there, that
appreciation for and excitement about the
fact that the world is not as simple as it
might seem, I find myself not wanting to do
that thing, and sometimes I don’t even know
why until I check in, and I’m like, yeah,
it’s just ‘cause it doesn’t do the thing
that I want to be doing.
That thing, imagining complexly, has become
a really big part of what we do and who we are.
Now, most of the people watching this probably
don’t know that we have a company that produces
a bunch of different content, and it has a
name, and it’s called EcoGeek.
And it’s called EcoGeek because I started
a blog in 2005 called EcoGeek, and it’s
the reason I started my first company, and
when I did that, I had an LLC, and I figured
I might as well make all of my other stuff
happen under the same thing, and it’s been
so long now that I’ve been using this name
that it doesn’t really apply anymore.
So this week, after years of thinking about
this and never being able to settle on a name,
we are changing our name of the company that
produces the content.
We have called it Complexly, because the world
is not simple, and we will never truly understand
our universe or each other or even ourselves.
The process is as powerful as the outcome,
and the more you know, the more wonderful
knowing becomes.
Because we want to imagine things complexly,
and because we want to help other people do it, too.
John, I’ll see you on Tuesday.